I recently got a second job met my boss
at least a week ago over the weekend and
she hasn't seem like she's really the
nicest person she's very rude um when I
first met her we went um to do some
training and she got upset that I had
brought a packed lunch with me to work
um and then yesterday she called me and
because I've been asking so many
questions because I new to the place um
and I haven't really gotten the proper
training that I've been asking questions
and she called me Annoying for asking
her questions regarding my job and I
just don't really know how to handle a
person like that who is angry all the
time this isn't worth putting up with
she's not going to change this is a
woman who got upset with you because you
brought a packed lunch how dare you who
gets irritated over somebody packing
their lunch